Okay.
Uh,
moving then as quickly as possible
into our subject matter for today.
Uh,
we began a series of lectures on various
aspects of 20th century formalism,
a big word,
uh,
at the end of our run through the
varieties of 20th century formalism.
I hope it doesn't seem quite as
big and that it's many meanings,
uh,
but finite number of meanings
have been made clear to you. Uh,
in the meantime, uh, this
aspect of our subject, uh,
is that is to say what we're taking
up this week is as much really,
you remember in the first lecture I
said there's a difference between the
history of criticism and
theory of literature. Uh,
one difference being history of criticism
has a great deal to do with literary
evaluation.
That is to say,
why do we care about literature and how
can we find means of saying that it's
good or not good?
Um,
this is an aspect of thought concerning
literature that tends to fall out of
literary theory, but not out of the
materials that we're reading this week.
You can see that when whims sat and
Beardsley talk about the success of the
poem, they understand the
whole critical enterprise,
including its theoretical underpinnings.
The question, what is a poem?
The question,
how should we best read it?
That the whole enterprise is still
geared toward a literary evaluation.
And that's,
and that makes this subject matter that
we'll be discussing this week. As I say,
as much a part of the history of
criticism as it is of literary theory,
we're going to be reading it with
a theory spin. Uh, that is to say,
we're going to focus on the question,
what a poem is, and the question,
what criteria should we invoke
in order to read it, uh,
for the best and correctly.
Uh,
but there are other ways of approaching
this material. Uh, in any case,
a website Beardsley,
uh,
is act was actually a philosopher
who taught at temple university,
a good friend of his, a in the
book in which this, uh, the essay,
the intentional fallacy appeared
a book called the verbal icon, uh,
women's that collaborated with
Monro Beardsley on three essays. Uh,
and this is one of them.
Uh,
so we try to remember to say
William Sat and Beardsley,
even though it is what it is
when sat who taught at Yale,
that in itself needn't be significance,
except that the new critics,
the school of critics do,
which he belonged,
have always been identified with
Yale and indeed consolidate it.
A kind of teaching method and
attitude toward literature,
which constituted the first wave,
uh,
first of two waves of
involvement in literary theory,
uh,
which amount to the Yale English and
comparative Literature Department's claims
to fame. Uh, the new
critics, um, many of the,
many of those figures who belonged
to the new critics did much of their
important work before they arrived at
Yale. Uh, others never were at Yale.
And yet at the same time, it's a
movement closely associated with this,
with this institution.
When I arrived at Yale,
a website was still teaching clearance.
Brooks was still teaching. Uh,
and so I feel a kind of per
personal continuity, uh,
with these figures, uh, and understand as,
as we all will more fully
later on the way in which, uh,
the style and emphasis on style of close
reading that evolved within the new
criticism,
um,
meaningfully and importantly left its
mark on much subsequent criticism and
theory that hasn't,
uh,
in fact always acknowledged the new
criticism perhaps to the extent that it
might have.
Um,
what I'll say because much of this should
be reserved for next time when I talk
about cleaning,
it's Brooks and returned to the whole
subject to the new criticism and the way
in which it's viewed historically.
So much of it can be reverted
for reserve for next time.
But what I do want to say now is this,
if it weren't for the new critics,
none of you probably would have been
able to sit patiently through any of your
middle or high school English classes.
When Clarence Brooks and Robert
Penn Warren published a book called
understanding poetry first published
1939 and then subsequently reissued again
and again and again as
it swept the country.
Suddenly school teachers had a way of
keeping kids in the classroom for 50
minutes,
close reading the idea that you could
take a text and do things with it,
that the, that the interpretation of a
taxed wasn't just a matter of saying,
Oh yes,
it's about this and isn't it beautiful?
Reciting the text, emoting over
it and theorizing about it. Uh,
and then looking around
for something else to say.
It was no longer a question of doing that.
It was a question of constructing
and elaborate formal edifice to which
everybody can, could contribute.
Students got excited about it.
They saw certain patterns or certain
ways of elaborating patterns that the
teachers were talking about.
And Lo and behold,
the 50 minutes was over and everybody
had had a pretty good time. Uh,
this, this had never happened
in an English class before.
Seriously, your English majors
because of the new criticism, I admit,
especially if you went to
private school, this, this, this,
this way of teaching did not perhaps quite
so much, uh, for a variety of reasons,
uh, permeate published public
school literature teaching. Uh,
but it was simply as a result
of understanding poetry. Uh,
the way to go. It took time. If
you had more than 50 minutes,
you could actually make ample use of it.
A Tsl at who is in many ways
associated with the new criticism.
Some of one of its intellectual forbears
nevertheless took a somewhat dim view
of it and called it lemon
squeezer criticism, you know, but,
but what this meant is,
you know, it takes time.
You gotta squeeze absolutely
everything out of it. Uh,
and so it was ideal from the
standpoint of teaching. And it was,
it seems to me also wonderfully
galvanizing intellectually
because p because it
really did make people think,
look how intricate what I thought
was simple turns out to be,
uh, the new criticism, uh,
incontestably and without rival created
an atmosphere in which it was okay to
notice that things were a little more
difficult than they'd been supposed to be.
And this in itself,
uh,
was extraordinarily
useful and constructive,
not just for scope, subsequent
literary theory, I think,
but for the way in which English teaching
actually can help people think better.
Uh, all of this, the new criticism
had a great deal to do with,
um,
and when I talk next time about the way
in which it's been vilified for the last
40 or 50 years, naturally
I will have this, uh, in,
in the back of my mind. So
in any case, in any case,
where did this preoccupation with form?
Because we're beginning to think about
the way in which theory can preoccupy but
not necessarily,
but can preoccupied itself with form.
Where does it come from? Well,
needless to say, I'm about to say,
it goes back to the beginning.
You know,
when Plato Writes His
Republic and devotes book 10,
as I'm sure most of you
know, to an argument, uh,
in effect banishing the poets
from the ideal republic.
Part of the argument is
that poets are terrible.
Annotators they imitate reality
as badly as they possibly can.
Uh,
not,
it's not there three times removed
from the ideal forms of objects.
In reality, there are hopeless
mass. They get everything wrong. Uh,
they think that a stick reflect refracted
in the water is therefore a crooked
stick.
They're subject to every conceivable
kind of illusion not to be trusted,
and Socrates calls them liars.
Okay. Now, when Aristotle,
when Aristotle writes his poetics, he
does so and, and this is true, and,
and, and, and rewards
and rewards scrutiny.
If one thinks carefully about the poetics,
he does so very consciously in refutation
of Plato's arguments in the republic
and one perhaps the
keystone of this reputation.
Refutation is simply this.
Plato says,
poets imitate be at badly.
Aristotle says,
this is a category mistake because
poets don't imitate reality.
Poets don't imitate,
says Aristotle things as they are.
They imitate things as they should be.
And other words,
the business of poets is to organize,
to bring form,
to bear on the messiness
of reality and in so doing,
to construct not exactly not an alternate
reality in the sense that it has
nothing to do with the real world.
That is to say it doesn't mention the
real world or at somehow or another
advance, you know, human beings made
out of chocolate or something like that,
but ideally rises the element's existing
in the real world such that it's object
is something other than reality as such.
And this is really the origin of
formalism. Aristotle is considered,
uh,
the ancestor of the varying
sorts of thought about form.
And it's this move that's moved
that he makes in the poetics, uh,
that in genders,
this possibility.
Now turning to your sheet in the early,
early modern period,
the poet and courtier,
Sir Philip Sidney wrote an elegant,
really wonderfully written defense of
poetry and want addition called the
apology for Posey.
And in this edition he develops a while
actually a fervent admirer of Plato.
He nevertheless develops this
idea of Aristotle with, uh,
with a remarkable, uh,
rhetorical ingenuity.
Uh,
and I think very impressively lays out
the case that Aristotle first makes a
first passage on your sheet said,
and he's talking about the various
kinds of discourse, divinity, hymnody,
science, philosophy, history.
And I was all the ways in which you
can contribute to a human betterment,
human welfare. And he says all
but one of them. There is, is,
is a serving science that is to say it
is subservient to the natural world.
It's, its importance is that
it refers to that world.
The first sentence of your hand,
of your passage,
there is no art but one delivered to
mankind that hath not the works of nature
for his principle
object. This, by the way,
although it's not exactly a
work of nature, this by the way,
is why even that which is incontestably
better than secular poetry hymnity and
also divine knowledge theology.
That's why even these fields,
which are the supreme fields,
are also serving sciences.
They are subservient to an
idea that they have to express,
which is the idea of God and God is real.
Nobody.
I mean we're, we're just
sort of, if there's,
there's no sense that we're making
God up in this kind of discourse.
Sydney's a devout, uh, uh, uh,
a devoutly religious person, uh,
and there is no scent.
There's no semblance of
doubt in his attitude. Uh,
and yet he is saying something very
special about the poet who is somewhere in
between divinity and the other sorts
of discourse with which poetry is
traditionally in rivalry,
science, philosophy and history.
And he says,
this is what's unique about poetry.
Only the poet disdaining to be
tied to any such subjection,
subjection,
in other words,
to things as they are to standing to be
tied to any such subjection lifted up
with the vigor of his own invention.
Duff grow any fact,
another nature,
he nothing affirms and
therefore never live.
In other words,
Plato is wrong.
The poet is not a liar because he's not
talking about anything that's verifiable
or falsifiable.
He is simply talking about the parameters
of the world he has brought into
being. Sydney thinks of it as a co,
as a kind of magic. Uh, he invokes,
for example, the science of the
pseudoscience of alchemy. The, the poet,
he says range is freely within
the Zodiac of his own wit.
He also invokes the pseudo science.
I'm sorry, I meant to say astrology.
Uh,
he also invokes the pseudoscience of
alchemy when he says that the poet in
habits of brazen world and have this
brazen brass of this brazen world,
he makes a golden world.
In other words,
poetry is transformational in
representing not things as they are,
but things as they should be.
It transforms reality.
All right,
so this is an argument which an outline
a once again justifies the idea of
literature as formed as that which
brings form to bear on the chaos and
messiness of the real.
Now I hit,
I don't mean to say things
just stood as Sydney said.
They were until you get to con,
a great deal happens.
But an aspect of cons,
famous Copernican revolution and the
history of philosophy is his ideas about
aesthetics and the beautiful and about
the special faculty that he believes,
uh,
has to do with and mediates our
aesthetic understanding of things.
A faculty which he calls the judgment
so that in the critique of judgment 1790
he outlines a philosophy of the
beautiful and have the means whereby the
judgment makes judgments of the beautiful.
He does a great deal else in it,
but I'm isolating this strand,
which is what's relevant to what
we're talking about in many ways.
Con Without knowing anything about Sydney,
nevertheless follows from Sydney,
particularly in this, as you'll see, I'm
going to look sort of with some carrot,
these passages so all will become clear,
but particularly in this Sydney and,
and I didn't exactly quote the
passage in which Sydney does this,
but I urged you to believe that he does.
Sydney actually racks poetry somewhere
between divinity and the other sciences.
In other words, poetry is not the supreme
thing that that that a person can do.
Sydney believed this so much in fact
that when he knew himself to be dying,
having been mortally wounded in a battle,
he ordered that all of his own poems
be burned. I mean, he had, you know,
from the standpoint of a devout person,
he had no doubt that poetry
was inferior to divinity.
Now in a way,
that's what [inaudible] saying too,
and the passages you'll read,
you'll see that it's that the point is
not that art and the judgment of the
beautiful is the supreme thing
that humanity can be engaged with.
The point is only that it has a special
characteristic that nothing else has.
That's the point that this whole
tradition is trying to make.
So this is the way can't puts
attorney first to the second passage.
The pleasant and the good.
Both have a reference to
the faculty of Desire,
the pleasant as the way in which our
Appleton see our sensuous faculty,
which comp calls. The understanding
by the way, understands things.
Things are either pleasant or unpleasant.
The good on the contrary is the way in
which our cognitive and moral faculty,
which comp calls the reason,
understands things.
Things are either to be approved
of or not to be approved of.
But in each case,
as con argues,
they have a reference to the
faculty of Desire. I want,
I don't want, I approve, I disapprove,
and they bring with them the former.
That is to say the pleasant,
a satisfaction pathologically
conditioned the ladder,
a pure, practical,
purposeful satisfaction,
which is determined not merely by
the representation of the object.
That is to say by the, by the fact that
the representative object exists for me.
Right? Not Merely by the
representation of the object,
but also by the represented connection
of the subject with the existence of the
object. In other words, by the way
in which I want it or don't want it,
approve of it or don't approve it,
my subjectivity, in other words,
determines my attitude toward it.
Whereas Khan,
what God is saying is that my attitude
of that which simply stands before us as
what is neither pleasant nor good
but is rather something else,
isn't,
doesn't exist for me.
It exists in and for itself.
The next passage taste is the faculty
of judging of an object or a method of
representing it by an entirely
disinterested satisfaction
or dissatisfaction.
In other words, yeah, I still
like it or don't like it,
but my liking has nothing to do
either with desire or with approval.
Moral political as the case may be.
I just like it or I just don't like
it according to principles that can be
understood as arising from the faculty
of Judgment and not from the Faculty of
the understanding which is a petitive
and the faculty of reason which is moral.
So with that said, ah, the PA
perhaps just to add to that,
the fourth passage,
uh,
beauty is the form of the
purposive nus of an object.
So far as it is perceived in it without
any representation of a purpose.
Whoa. You'll say, well let's
hunt makes a distinction between
the purposive and the purpose full.
What is the distinction? The purpose
full as the purpose of the object.
In practical terms,
what can it do?
What can it do for me?
How does it go to work and the world?
What is its function among other objects?
What bearing does it have
on in particular my life.
But the purposiveness of the object is
the way in which it is sufficient unto
itself.
It has its own purpose,
which is not a purpose that has any
bearing necessarily on anything else.
It has in other words
and internal coherence.
It has a dynamism of parts
that is strictly with
reference to its own existence.
It is a form,
it is a form and that form,
because we can see it has structure
because we can see it has organization and
complexity is purposive.
That is to say it has it,
it manifests its self sufficiency.
So that's cons. Famous distinction
between the purpose of which is the,
uh, organization of an aesthetic
object and the purpose full,
which is the organization of
any object insofar as it's, it,
it goes to work in the world or for us.
And aesthetic object can be purposeful.
That is to say,
we can view it as purposeful.
Uh, I see a naked body, uh,
which the art historians call a nude.
Uh,
I don't accept that it's merely a
nude I wanted or I disapprove of it.
Um, and Lo and behold,
it's no longer aesthetic.
I'll come back to that in a moment,
but I hope you can see that that is a
distinction between the purpose of and the
purposeful. Now, um,
just in order to reprise these
important distinctions, uh,
uh,
I want to turn to a passage from in
Samuel Coleridge who is at least on this
occasion a disciple of Khan and his,
I think usefully paraphrasing
the arguments of con that
we've just been engaged
in fifth passage on your sheet.
The beautiful says Coleridge is that wants
distinguished both from the agreeable
which has beneath it and notice the
sort of stationing of the beautiful as
Sydney stations.
It between let's,
let's beneath it and what's
above it from the agreeable,
which has beneath it and from the good,
which is above it for both
these necessarily have an
interest attached to them
both act on the will and excite a desire
for the actual existence of the image
or idea contemplated while
the sense of beauty rest,
gratified in the mirror,
contemplation or intuition.
Regardless whether it be a
fictitious Apollo or a real,
and Tim says,
in other words,
they judgment of beauty does not depend
on the existence of the object for its
satisfaction.
Now,
Oscar Wilde ever the wag and a person
who put more good literary theory in ways
that didn't seem like
literary theory at all. Uh,
perhaps in the entire history of thinking
about the subject says in the famous
series of Aphorisms, aphorisms, which,
which constitute his preface
to the picture of Dorian Gray.
He concludes this series of Aphorisms
by winking at us and saying all art is
quite useless.
I hope that after reading these passages
and enduring the explication of them
that you've just heard,
you can immediately see what wild means
by saying all art is quite useless.
He's appropriating a term of opprobrium,
you know,
and the utilitarian tradition.
Oh my goodness, that's
something would be useless,
right?
He's appropriating a term of a
program and pointing out that it is an
extraordinarily unique thing about art,
that it's useless.
And other words that it appeals to know
merely a pedal [inaudible] or other form
of subjective interest.
We don't have to have an interest in
it and the sense of owning part of a
company,
we don't have to have an interest
in it in order to appreciate it.
In other words,
we can be objective about it.
We can distance ourselves from our,
from our subjective wants and needs and
likes and dislikes and we can coexist
with it and I happy and constructive way
that is good for both of us because if
we recognize that there are things in
the world which have intrinsic value and
importance and what we call beauty and
yet are not the things that we covered or
wish to banish,
we recognize in ourselves the capacity
for it disinterestedness we recognize in
ourselves a virtue which is considered
to be the cornerstone of many systems of
moral understanding to realize that
we're not interested in everything and
merely for that reason take a view of
things but that there are things that we
don't have to have that kind of interest
in and can nevertheless recognize as
self sufficient and valuable is important.
The suggestion is wild suggestion,
but I think also constantly Justin before
him is important for our recognition
of our own value.
And by the same token all this
harping on the autonomy of art.
That is to say the self
sufficiency of the art,
the way in which it's not
dependent on anything.
As soon as Sydney says the way in which
it's not a serving science existing
merely to represent things
other than itself. All right.
The way in which this is possible for
art is also as our own capacity to be
disinterested is a way of
acknowledging that freedom exists,
that I am free,
that things are free,
things are free from my
instrumental interest in them.
So that in general,
what's implicit in this view of art and
this view of human judgment and what
makes it so important and the history
of thought is that once again,
and this is not the first time we've
brought this up and in these lectures and
won't be the last,
is that once again,
it's a way of recognizing that in addition
to all the other things that we are,
some of them wonderful.
In addition to all of that,
we are also free.
There is in us at least an element that
is free in dependent serving nothing
autonomous.
And this idea of our freedom and by
implication of the freedom of other things
from our instrumental entrusts is what
sustains the formalist tradition and
against various kinds of criticism
and objection that will be taking up,
uh,
in turn as the case arises,
sustains and keeps bringing back into
the history of thought on these subjects.
The notion that form simply
for its own sake as this,
as,
as the notorious aesthetist movement at
the end of the 19th century put it is
valuable. All right. Now,
John Crowe ransom,
who was never at Yale,
but nevertheless, uh, um,
one of the founders or first members of
a self identified school of figures who
called themselves the new critics,
um,
published a book called the new criticism.
And that's where,
and that's where the term
the new critics comes from.
You may have noticed in your whims
that essay that there's a footnote to
somebody named Joel Spingarn who wrote
an essay called the new criticism in 1924
not to worry, that has nothing
to do with the new criticism.
That just means criticism, which is
race and different matter altogether.
By the same token, uh,
there is a, there the,
the work of Roland backed at his,
some of his contemporaries,
Palais whom I mentioned, John
Stocker Verbinski and others, ah,
was called in the French Press, La
Nouvelle Critique. And that too,
you know, then is, uh, a,
an instance of the new
criticism being used as a term.
But that too has nothing to do with
our subject. Uh, the new critics,
the American new critics, as they
are sometimes identified. Uh,
we're a school and I,
and I use that advisedly because
they're self identified as a group.
We're a school of people who evolved
this idea of the independent status,
uh, um, ransom calls it, uh,
a discreet ontological object,
the independent status of the work of art,
uh,
and the means whereby it can be
appreciated as independent in all of its,
of all of, in all of its
complexity. Uh, and the first foray,
our first foray into the thinking of
this school will be our rating of whimsy
and beards leaves, uh, the intentional
fallacy, which I'll get to in a minute,
but simply as a reprise, uh, take a
look at the two passages from ransom,
which complete what's on your
sheet, uh, and which, um, uh,
I think you can see,
create a link between the sort of
thinking you've encountered in reading.
The intentional fallacy and the tradition
that I've been trying to describe
passage seven ought to be
completely transparent to
you now because it is simply
a paraphrase of the passages I've
given you from con and Coleridge.
The experience says ransom,
the experience called beauty is beyond
the powerful ethical will precisely as it
is beyond the animal passion.
And indeed these last two are
competitive and coordinate.
In other words,
what they have in common with each other
ethical will and animal passion is that
they're both grounded in interest. Right?
That's, I mean, that's the point of,
you know, sir, kind of Clarks
were the nude, you know, I mean,
we have for the naked human being as
viewed both by the appetites and by moral
reason as a common term
from the standpoint,
both of what con calls the understanding
and from what Kant calls the reason the,
the, the expression naked body
is just fine. But if we've got,
but if we do believe
there's another category,
the aesthetic viewed by an independent
faculty called the judgment,
we need another word when we're
looking. I mean, you know, I mean,
modern painters like Philip Pearlstein
and Lucien Freud would strongly disagree,
but in a way, that's the point. When we're
looking at a painting of a naked body,
we not say, oh, that's a naked body.
We say that's a nude. And that,
and that distinction, that
distinction is what, uh, as it were,
bears out the implicit way,
the semi conscious way in which all of
us acknowledged there to be a category
that we call the aesthetic judgment.
On the other hand,
a lot of people think it's, it's
all hokum. Uh, and in fact, in fact,
the predominant view in the 20th century
has been that there's no such thing as
disinterestedness, uh,
that we're looking at. Uh,
we formed, we have an interest
in, uh, and form views of,
and that, um, and that
this content moment of, of,
of dispassionate or disinterested
contemplation is what, uh,
the early 20th century critic I a
Richards called a phantom aesthetic state.
Uh, and so the predominant view is
of this kind, but you know, I mean,
just to do it justice in passing,
there is a certain sense is they're
not in which we suddenly find ourselves
without meaning to. And
without being simply victims
of sort of cultural tyranny,
we suddenly find ourselves standing in
front of something clasping our hands
tilting our head and feeling somehow or
another different from the way we feel
when we typically look at
things. And that too, you know,
is an intuitive way of saying
yes, something like this. However,
rigorously we can define it or defend it.
Something like this does seem to go on
in our minds at certain kinds of moments
of experience.
You know,
we just feel differently looking
at a certain work of art.
Then we feel, uh, or a
certain landscape, let's say.
Then we feel looking at other sorts
of things. Maybe we don't know why.
Maybe we doubt that the differences is
absolute in the way that caught wants to
insist it is.
But nevertheless,
we have intendancy feelings of this kind
and we should acknowledge them because
again, uh, at least in terms of
it's of, of, of a, of a, of a,
a weak understanding of these positions,
it,
it does tend to justify them,
at least,
at least it explains to us why people
can't have had such thoughts. Okay.
When set
website right off, I keep saying women
side, again, its whims that and leave,
but I already explained,
you know how that is, um,
whims that right off the bat attacks what
he calls the romantic understanding of
literature.
Now what does he mean by romantic?
It's the attitude which supposes
that a poem and that's whims.
That's privileged privileged word,
which I'll try to explain that a poem
is an expression that is to say is the
expression of some passion or profound
genius working its way into a form,
but that the important thing
is the expression this much,
by the way,
when's that hasn't common with God I'm
or because you know God I'm or doesn't
talk much about authors either.
And Garber is interested in what he calls,
meaning the subject matter dissolve,
right?
He's not interested in in your sort
of expression of that meaning or my
expression of that. Meaning he's, he's,
he's interested in the way in which a
reader can come to terms with a meaning.
And that much as I say,
despite the profoundly different
nature of their projects, uh,
winds that and got him or have in common
so upon is not an expression but an
independent object with
a self contained meaning.
And if this meaning is not self
evident to the attentive reader,
then we don't judge the poem a success.
This is where evaluation comes in.
The success or failure of a DePaul of,
of a poem depends on the
realization of meaning.
It doesn't depend on are
going to the archive.
Finding out what the author
said in his letters about it,
finding out what he told his friends,
what he told the newspapers.
It doesn't involve any of that.
If the meaning is not clear in the poem,
we judge the poem a failure.
We don't refer.
We have no reason to refer.
If we respect the autonomy
of the poem as such,
we don't refer,
we don't appeal to an authorial intention.
Hence on page eight 11 lefthand column.
But third of the way down the design
or intention of the author is neither
available nor desirable as a standard
for judging the success of a work of
literary art.
So that and and,
and it follows from this that um,
even a short poem,
even a short lyric poem and here you
could see whims that following food co.
I mean he's obviously not following
anticipating Fuko and again they have
nothing to do with each other,
but there is this overlap.
Even a short poem doesn't
really have an author.
It has a speaker,
a figure speaking in the poem that
needs to be understood dramatically.
That is to say as though the poem,
we're one of Browning's or ts
Elliot's dramatic monologues.
In other words,
so so that the speaker of any poem on
websites of you is this beaker and doubt
with a certain character,
a certain viewpoint,
a certain argument to be put forward
and that in order and that our concern
about the speaker has to be a concern
within the poem of the way in which this
character is elaborated and not,
uh,
reinforced somehow by biographical
reference to that which is not the speaker
but the author standing back
there somewhere behind the poem.
Now,
why focus on the poem?
Notice we never hear about literature.
We never had,
we never even hear about poetry.
The object of attention for an
analysis of this kind is the poem.
While the poem is as John
as John Dunn puts it,
a little world made cunningly.
It's a microcosm.
It is a distillation or quintessence.
It is a model,
in other words,
for the way in which literature
can be understood as world making.
Not a representation again
of things as they are,
but of things as they should be.
Whereas things whereas they should be is
not whereby things as they should be is
not necessarily an ideal,
but rather that which is formal,
that which is organized that which
has a coherence and make sense self
sufficiently and within its self.
That's why poem the poem,
the lyric poem is privileged among the
forms of literary discourse in the new
criticism.
All literature is by implication a poem,
but the poem is the privileged site of
analysis whereby this broader statement
can be made to seem reasonable.
Hence the emphasis on,
on the poem, um, the,
the absence of the romantic word poetry,
uh,
is therefore not in significant poetry,
is that which just sort
of spills out of me.
It's by spontaneous overflow
of powerful feelings.
Nevermind that,
uh,
the new criticism and isn't interested
in spontaneous overflows of powerful
feelings. Whims sat has his little
joke about drinking a pint of beer,
taking a walk, you know, I mean,
that's sort of the new criticism just
isn't interested in those sorts of
spontaneous overflow. Uh,
sorry, I, I won't go there.
Um, but in any case, uh,
he goes, he goes on, he
goes on to say, all right,
if we're focused on the work of
art in and of itself, on the poem,
we obviously in thinking
about what it means,
need to come to terms with
three kinds of evidence.
That is to say some things have a bearing
on what it means and some things don't.
What does have a bearing is language.
That is to say words in the public domain,
which all of us share and which we can
study in order to come to terms with the
exact meaning of the poem. A
certain word. And this is of course,
what kept you in your high
school classes for so long.
A certain word has five or
six different meanings. Uh,
the new criticism delights in showing
how all five or six of those meetings do
have some bearing on the meaning of
the Po. That's all legitimate evidence.
That is what one uses to build up the
structure of the interpretation of the
pond. What is not relevant is
what I've mentioned already. Uh,
what the author said about
the palm, uh, in letters, uh,
two friends, two newspapers and
so on, uh, that has no relevance.
Then when's that acknowledges that
there's a sort of Massey third category of
evidence which has to do with language
and is therefore a legitimate to a point,
but also has to do with the
author's idiosyncrasies.
That is to say the way that
author in particular use language,
certain codery words,
uh,
a simply a private misunderstanding
of certain words. Uh, uh,
you know, you got to know when you're
reading Whitman what he means by Comarado.
You know, it's not exactly what the
rest of us typically mean. Uh, when we,
when we went, well, we don't use that
word exactly, but, but it's what we,
what we typically mean when we speak
of comrades or a comradeship. Uh,
there is an,
in other words,
the word is loaded in ways that women
that would probably acknowledge need to be
taken into account if we're going
to understand what Whitman is up to.
Now this is very tricky.
And he spends the rest of his essay
talking about the murky boundaries between
evidence type of evidence to which
is out of play and type of evidence.
Three,
which may be in play but has to be dealt
with in a gingerly and careful way.
Um, and, but I'm more interested
actually in a footnote,
which arises from this argument about
the idiosyncratic nature of language as a
particular author may use it
because the footnote says,
you know what,
that's just one consideration we bring
to bear on the function of language and a
poem.
This is this footnote number 11,
bottom of page 18 for eight 14 over to
eight 15 is just about as devastating and
counterintuitive a pronouncement as is
made anywhere in our entire syllabus.
I mean, you know, the, the new critics,
what you would think you would find, uh,
the most,
the most earth shattering pronouncement,
that one that anybody could ever
possibly make in the new critics. Well,
look at this footnote and the history
of words after a poem is written,
may contribute meanings,
which if relevant to the original pattern,
should not be ruled out by a scruple
about intention that is bold.
The great creator raised his plastic arm,
all right,
everybody knows Aiken signed,
didn't mean Paula didn't mean polymers,
but now we're all into cyber borgs
and we're, you know, we, we, we,
we take all of this very seriously and it,
and it,
in a way it's a tribute to the great
creator and also an of the fact that the
great creator lives in the terminal
moment. He's not subject to history.
I mean the great creator new in the 18th
century that someday plastic would mean
polymer, right? And, and, and
obviously that's, that's one of the,
one of the divine attributes.
Therefore,
if the great creator chooses
to raise his prosthetic limb,
that is simply a way of understanding
what it is like to be everything
omnipotent and omniscient in the
eternal moment. In other words,
if you take wind sites,
11th footnotes, seriously,
that is a perfectly legitimate way.
Not too ironically
undermine Aiken sides line.
But actually to reinforce it and to
give it a kind of formal richness,
which it does not otherwise have.
Uh,
I realized that I'm out of time.
So I'll begin the next lecture by talking
about a bomb of Yeats called Lapis
lazily written in 1935.
Uh,
and which he talks about the way in which
people who build up things that have
been destroyed are always gay.
And of course,
and of course, nature doesn't
mean we say invoking intention.
Nature doesn't mean that
they're always gay. Uh,
he is using the English translation
of the German word ferulic from,
from a niche as the gay
science. Uh, he is, uh,
a,
an astute and,
and careful reader of Nita and in some
ways elaborating on what nature says in
that book, in his poem, Lapis Lazily.
But beginning of the next lecture,
we will do the same thing with the word
gay that we've just done with the word
plastic. And then we will go ahead,
uh, and we will consider the SIF,
Clarence Brooks and other
aspects of the new criticism.